- Thanks to Dashlane for
keeping Legal Eagle in the air.
Have you ever wanted to
know how a lawsuit works?
Most people think of lawsuits
as being these big scary animals
that are completely opaque and esoteric.
But the truth is,
they are vital to the
functioning of our society
and can right wrongs where they occur.
But today I wanna demystify the process
so that if you ever need to use a lawsuit
or find yourself in the middle of one,
you'll at least know how they operate.
Hey Legal Eagles, it's time
to think like a lawyer.
Today we are covering civil lawsuits
or as most people refer
to them, just lawsuits.
As always, be sure to
subscribe and comment
in the form of an objection,
which I will either sustain or overrule.
I wanted to cover lawsuits today
because there are a lot of misconceptions
about how the civil process works.
And let me start out this discussion
by drawing a distinction
between the civil process of law
and the criminal process.
The criminal process is probably the one
that you see most often
on TV and in movies.
That is where you have committed a crime
and you are prosecuted by the state.
And generally the penalties
for a criminal offense
is jail time.
Sometimes there are monetary penalties
that go along with a crime
but the bottom line is
that generally speaking
the criminal process involves the state
prosecuting you for
crimes against society.
The civil process on the
other hand is different.
The civil process is
how you get compensation
for damages that are
caused by another person.
Damages that are caused
in the form of usually
a breach of contract
or what we call torts,
which are civil wrongs,
things that are not crimes
but are violations of norms such
that we believe that one person
should compensate the other.
Generally speaking, the end
goal of the civil process
is to receive monetary compensation
for the wrongs that you have suffered.
As opposed to the criminal process
where you have done a
wrong against society
and you can go to jail as a result.
So today we're going to be
talking exclusively about
the civil law process,
not the criminal process
and the main tool of the civil process
which is of course is the lawsuit.
Now of course, there are
always a million exceptions
to the things I'm going to talk about
which is why there are lawyers
and you should always consult a lawyer
before engaging in any
kind of civil process.
But today I wanna go
over the broad strokes
so you have a general idea
of how a lawsuit works.
A lawsuit starts with
what's called a complaint.
A complaint is the document
that initiates your civil suit
against somebody else.
It require a couple of things.
Primarily it is your factual
statement of allegations
as to what happened.
How you have been wronged
and why you are entitled to
some sort of compensation.
It contains a statement of
proper jurisdiction and venue
to show that this
particular court is the one
that should be hearing
this particular lawsuit.
But for the most part it contains
your factual allegations.
Your story of what happened.
And at the end of the complaint
there Is this statement of law
that explains the causes of action
that give rise to your particular claim.
So after you have the factual statement
about what happened,
you'll have the legal statement
about why those particular facts
fit the elements of a particular
cause of action or claim
and that entitles you to
some sort of compensation.
So for example, a few weeks back I covered
the Fornite dance controversy.
Where certain artists were
suing video game manufacturers,
claiming that they had stolen
their copyrighted dance.
In their complaints,
they laid out that
these particular artists
had in fact created a copyrightable works
in the form of dances.
So that was the factual predicate.
They laid out that the
video game manufacturers
had taken these copyrighted works,
used them without permission,
again the factual predicate,
and then at the end they stated
that this was a violation
of copyright law,
citing to the federal standard
for copyright infringement.
So that's an example what
the complaint looks like,
it's the initiating document,
it contains the factual
and legal reasoning
for why you think you
should get compensation
from another person.
The next step after
someone files a complaint,
generally speaking, is
to file what's called
an answer or a motion to dismiss.
The person who files the complaint
is called the plaintiff.
And generally speaking,
the person who responds to the
complaint is the defendant.
Now once the plaintiff
files the complaint,
the defendant has basically two options.
One is called an answer,
the other is called a motion to dismiss.
The answer, not surprisingly,
is an answering document to the complaint.
Which goes line by line
over the factual allegations
in the complaint and either admits
to those particular facts or denies them.
Now it might seem strange to
admit anything in a complaint
but really in any given lawsuit
there will be things
that both sides agree to,
facts that are not really in dispute
and facts that they deny and
that they say never happened.
So the purpose of the answer
is to stipulate the facts
that are not in dispute
and to deny the facts
that are in dispute.
The second option, if it is available,
is called a motion to dismiss.
A motion to dismiss
doesn't challenge the facts
of the complaint,
there will be time for
that later in the lawsuit.
The motion to dismiss simply says
that even if everything
that the plaintiff says
is 100% true from a factual standpoint,
it still doesn't give rise
to any kind of legal remedy.
It is legally invalid.
So let's say that someone
files a lawsuit against you
for being a big mean jerk face.
Well there's no cause of
action called jerk face.
The law doesn't allow
you to get compensation
just because someone
was a jerk face to you.
That might make you a bad person
but that doesn't mean that you have
an obligation to pay
them any sort of money.
However, let's say that
someone files a claim
for defamation.
Defamation requires one, a
false statement of a fact
rather than an opinion,
publication or communication
of that statement,
and fault amounting to at least negligence
and then suffering damages as a result
of that untrue fact statement.
Now let's assume that the
complaint alleging defamation
is 100% factually incorrect.
You either never said
the statement in question
or the statements are true and therefor
couldn't have been a false
fact that was communicated.
In that circumstance a motion
to dismiss wouldn't work.
Because a motion to dismiss
assumes that the facts in
the complaint are true.
A motion to dismiss only
tests the legal sufficiency
of the complaint.
And in this particular case,
someone has alleged legal
predicate for defamation.
There will be time later on to
show that the facts are wrong
but effectively at these early stages
the only things that you
can do as a defendant
are either answer or
file a motion to dismiss.
Which only tests the legal
sufficiency of the complaint
not the factual sufficiency.
And if you lose a motion to dismiss
then you will just have to answer
just like any other defendant.
So once the complaint and
answer have been filed
the court has said that
at least as alleged
there is legal sufficiency
for the lawsuit,
then what generally happens is
you proceed into what's called discovery.
Discovery is the process
by which both sides
give up all the information
that is relevant to
the particular lawsuit.
Both the claims that
the plaintiff is making
and any defenses that the defendant has.
Long gone are the days where
you can ambush people at trial.
Trial is really just the
tip of the lawsuit iceberg.
For the most part, most of
the lawsuit consists of this
factual discovery back and
forth because we've decided
that it is better for the judicial process
for people to have all of
the relevant information
that is necessary to
adjudicate these cases
before going to trial.
Discovery consists of essentially
requests from one side to the other
and then responses from that side
back to the original requesting side.
This includes things like interrogatories
which are questions that the
other side has to answer.
It includes document requests
where you request a certain
category of documents.
And unless it's objectionable,
the other side must respond
by providing all of those documents.
You'll often see on TV and movies,
people talking about
being buried in documents.
One way of responding to document requests
is to not look at them
discreetly and specifically
and just giving the
other side every document
that could be responsive to the request
that you have made.
So it's often in your best interest
to write your document
request in such a way
that you get the documents that you want
but don't create this really huge bourdon
from the other side
to compile hundreds of thousands
or millions of documents
as a result of these requests.
You need to thread that needle.
And of course discovery
also consists of depositions
which is where you get
to question a witness.
Witnesses are under oath,
they're responses are
recorded by a stenographer.
Recently I just reviewed
the movie The Social Network
which is really interesting
from my perspective
because it is told almost entirely
through deposition testimony.
And you can imagine that
when you're in a lawsuit
being able to question witnesses
and parties to that lawsuit
can be a very, very important tool
to find out what happened
in any particular legal situation.
It's a great way to get
evidence and to be able to
destroy the other side's
legal claims as well.
But of course the downside to
the factual discovery process
is that it is very resource intensive.
It takes a ton of time to draft requests,
to respond to requests.
And then of course to cull through
sometimes millions of pages of documents
just to look for the things
that support your case
or support your defense.
Discovery is what makes
up the vast majority
of litigating a lawsuit.
So generally speaking,
once factual discovery has
commenced or has completed,
one or both of the parties
will file what's called a
motion for summary judgment.
Now where a motion to dismiss
does not attach any evidence whatsoever
because it takes the allegations
and the complaint as true,
a motion for summary
judgment can use evidence.
You will compile some of the evidence
that you gathered through
document requests,
through interrogatories
and through depositions,
you will attach that to your motion
and it's basically a trial on paper.
The motion for summary judgement
is a way of ending a lawsuit
early without getting to trial.
But the downside is that both sides
effectively must agree to the
evidence that is undisputed.
And of course many
sides do in fact dispute
the evidence at the motion
for summary judgment stage.
But a judge will take
that into consideration
and will look at the evidence presented
and actually determine if the parties
really do dispute the evidence
or if the other side can
offer contradictory evidence.
So assuming that it's
the defendant that files
a motion for summary judgment
and says that even with undisputed
facts the lawsuit fails,
the plaintiff can respond to
a motion for summary judgment
by saying legally their
case is still sound
and that even with these undisputed facts
they are entitled to a legal remedy.
Or the plaintiff can beat a
motion for summary judgment
by demonstrating that in fact
the facts go different ways,
that there's contradictory evidence
and that the facts are disputed
in such a way that a
motion for summary judgment
should not be granted.
Now assuming that all motions
for summary judgment are denied,
that generally leads to pretrial motions
and what we call motions in limine
which are motions that deal
with evidentiary issues.
One thing you see in legal movies
and legal TV shows all the time
is that they have all of
these evidentiary disputes
in the middle of trial.
That's not particularly realistic.
For the most part, if you have evidence
that A, you think is
really, really important
and B, you think the other
side is going to contest
and not stipulate to the
admission of that evidence,
what you'll want to do
is file a pretrial motion
to allow that evidence to come in.
So for the most part, all
of the really important
evidentiary issues don't
happen in the middle of trial
where there's this Perry Mason moment
where you're not sure if the judge
is going to allow your
evidence to come in or not.
That's taken care of
months before the trial
in pretrial motions and motions in limine
because if the evidence
is really important
and you need it to come in,
you want to provide as much briefing
and as much legal reasoning
as to why it should come in.
Or legal reasoning as to why
the other side's evidence
should be kept out
because you'll never be able to do as much
in oral argument especially
on the day of trial.
After the pretrial issues are dealt with
that leads to trial.
Now less than 2% of all filed lawsuits
ever get anywhere close to trial.
For the most part,
most lawsuits are either
rejected at the motion stage
or they will settle ahead of time
long before you get to trial.
Because trial is incredibly expensive.
But assuming that you get to trial,
of course everybody knows
about opening statements
where each side will explain
what facts they intend to bring out
in that particular trial.
Then you go on to examinations
where you conduct the direct examination
of your witnesses, the
plaintiff goes first.
Then each individual
witness is cross-examined
by the defense.
Then the defense witnesses go
where the defendants will
provide their witnesses
who are examined and
cross-examined by the plaintiffs.
Then there are closing arguments
which is the one place
where you are allowed
to engage in argument.
Openings are generally
supposed to be argument free,
just explaining what kind
of facts are gonna come out.
Closing arguments is where you are able
to tie everything together.
And then after closing
argument the trier of fact,
whether that is a judge or a jury,
will render a decision about
which side wins or loses.
There can be an appeal.
On appeal, you're not retrying the facts,
the facts are set by the trial court.
On appeal the only
things that are at issue
are discreet legal issues.
With a given set of
facts the court of appeal
will look at the decisions
that the trial court made
and determine if they were legally correct
based on those facts.
Of course there are exceptions to this
but that's generally what's
happening when you appeal.
And by the way, I've heard
so many times people say,
I'm goin to appeal this all
the way to the Supreme Court.
No, no you're not.
The Supreme Court doesn't really review
run of the mill lawsuits.
The Supreme Court only takes a case
if there is a tricky
Constitutional question
or a question of first impression
that deals with federal laws.
Odds are, your lawsuit
doesn't come anywhere close
to those issues,
so there's no way you
will ever appeal your case
to the Supreme Court.
It's just not going to happen.
So that's how a basic civil lawsuit works.
Use this new found knowledge
for good, not for evil.
Of course, one group of people
that are constantly getting sued
are tech companies
because they can't seem to
keep your passwords secure.
Dashlane on the other hand,
protects your identity across the internet
by providing a tool that
generates strong passwords
and stores and auto fills them securely
everywhere on the internet.
Seamlessly across all of your devices.
It's also a VPN which
acts as an intermediary
to make sure that all of your
internet traffic is encrypted
even when you're on public Wi-Fi.
Try Dashlane free for 30
days at the link below
and Legal Eagles will get
10% off Dashlane premium
by using the promo code
legaleagle at checkout.
So click on the link, prevent hacks,
and I'll see you in court.